good evening
my name is bria baker i'm a senior in
seibert college and the president of
yale's chapter of the naacp
and i would like to thank you all for
joining us for tonight's keynote on
making black dreams matter
i am so excited to welcome back
president brooks the national president
of the naacp who graduated from yale law
school and spoke from this same pulpit
commemorating mlk while he was a student
the theme of tonight and this week in
general is the work continues making
black dreams matter
last semester we witnessed this
firsthand here at yale and at mizu and
princeton and many other institutions of
higher education
but youth activism has not been
exclusive to college campuses and we
also saw the efforts of youth in chicago
ohio and texas
across this nation youth are coming
together to continue the amazing work of
the heroes before us
and there is no greater way to honor
king's legacy than by continuing towards
the realization of his dream
in his speech i've been to the
mountaintop king made an important
comment
something is happening in our world the
masses of people are rising up
he concluded that speech with let us
rise up tonight with a greater readiness
let us stand with a greater
determination and let us move on in
these powerful days these days of
challenge to make america what it ought
to be
let us not just remember king on his
birthday or during black history month
let us remember him immobilizing let us
remember him through the efforts of next
yale
let us remember him by exerting our
freedom of speech to challenge what we
know to be unjust
and let us remember him and refusing to
shy away from the very important
conversations of inclusion diversity and
racial equality not just from african
americans but also for those of native
latinx and asian descent
we are the next wave of the movement and
that is why i am so thankful to you all
for coming tonight to hear from
president brooks on the work that began
all those years ago and how that
continues with us
so without further ado i will turn the
program over to shades of yale the co-ed
a cappella group and resident group of
the afro-american cultural center that
draws on the rich ethnic and musical
backgrounds of its members with a focus
on the music of the african diaspora
after their performance we will have
jonathan holloway dean of yale college
edmund s morgan professor of african
american studies and professor of
history and of american studies to
introduce our speaker president cornell
william brooks
thank you
okay
then
my
please
uh
foreign
me
sisters
ah
oh
so
oh
to paraphrase james baldwin
if the father can teach us to say yes
lord
the children can learn that most
precious word
amen
thank you yale shades of yale thank you
very much
good evening my name is jonathan
hollowam dean of yale college
i send greetings from peter salovey the
president of the institution who
desperately wishes he could be here when
he founded his schedule did not align
with his event
uh i believe he spent about an hour on
the phone talking with our guest speaker
that's right right yeah just wanting to
maybe a little more in fact um
uh i don't know the context of that
conversation
but
president salovey
wanted to make clear
that he wishes he were here in this
moment he's right now out of the country
i'd like to think he's with us all the
same
it is my great pleasure to welcome you
to yale university generally into
battelle chapel specifically for the
2016 martin luther king jr keynote
address
our speaker on this occasion is the
reverend cornell william brooks
president and ceo of the national
association for the advancement of
colored people
before i go into a proper introduction
up for our guest speaker
it is important to note that reverend
brooks brooks will be addressing us from
the same podium martin luther king jr
used when he came to campus
king visited yale on two separate
occasions
once in 1959 when he spoke on the future
of integration
and again in 1964 when he received an
honorary degree
if alumni were curious about king's
first visit an unsettling number were
horrified when then president kingman
brewster would deign to bestow upon king
yale's highest honor
yes some reporters and newspapers hailed
brewster's actions
but others lamented that yale was
honoring quote a petty criminal
king it is important to note had arrived
in new haven only two days after being
released from a florida jail where he
was being held for ordering food in a
whites only hotel
was yale a place
that affirmed the actions of a petty
criminal
brewster replied to those who questioned
the direction of the institutional's
ethical compass in the following manner
our educational our educational as well
as moral obligation is to reaffirm the
ideals we believe in
he added the effort to cure racial
injustice should not be allowed to
fester into war between the races
therefore it is especially important for
the institutional symbols of white
privilege to let it be known that they
share this cause
brewster as you know was writing during
during a moment when the nation was
engaged in a conversation about race
civil rights and citizenship that
demanded a new language if we were to
understand who we were as a nation
this is over 50 years ago lest we forget
and yet here we are in 2016
seven years into the present presidency
of the first african-american to hold
that office in a moment when we can open
up our newspapers read twitter feeds
turn on the television and scan social
media and sadly wonder
haven't we gone through this already
what happened to the promise of king's
dream what has come of the decades of
work that so many of our grandparents
mothers and fathers aunts and uncles
pursued in the hope that a future they
might not ever see
would look different from the present
that they knew
these are the questions that we asked
today
that so many are we're asking in this
very same space literally this very same
space just two months ago
thank goodness then
that we have someone like reverend
brooks who can offer us guidance
thank goodness then
that we have as our guest someone who
can talk to us about our present
challenges who can ground them in a
vernacular informed by politics and by
faith and you can speak with personal
experience about the journey that for
many
is translated into what is known as the
american dream
i look across our landscape and i see
that we are in need of translators in
this moment one when we spend too much
time sometimes it feels like all of the
time talking past each other
reverend brooks is such a person
and i thank goodness again that he is
with us today
in 2014 reverend brooks became the chief
executive of the naacp he is by training
and by inclination a civil rights
attorney a social justice advocate a
coalition builder and a fourth
generation ordained minister
he earned a bachelor of arts with honors
and political science from jackson state
university and a master of divinity from
boston university's school of theology
with a concentration in social ethics
and systematic theology
after seminary brooks earned a juris
doctorate from yale law school where he
served as a senior editor of the yale
law journal and member of the yale law
and policy review
while studying at boston university as a
martin of the king scholar brooks is
awarded both the oxfam leibman
fellowship for outstanding scholarship
and and promoting racial harmony and the
jefferson fellowship for outstanding
scholarship and excellence in preaching
prior to joining the naacp brooks led
the newark based new jersey institute
for social justice as president and ceo
there he directed the institute's
successful efforts to win the passage of
prisoner re-entry bills he developed
workforce training programs for
low-income hard-to-employ residents
he served the people
he laid the foundation so that others
could rebuild their lives as productive
and responsible citizens
in all of this work he served as a model
for the kind of sacrifice and vision
that we associate with martin luther
king jr
i also like to think that he served as a
model for the kind of person yields
aspires to send out into this world
so please
join me in welcoming home
reverend cornell brooks
good evening
it is such a delight
and humbling honor
to be
here
in a place
that i called home
for three years
now the last time i was in this pulpit
preaching the martin luther king
commemorative
sermon
it occurred
two days before
one of my exams at yale law school
so i arrive at this moment
slightly less stressed
this evening
there is a formal portion of the program
that speakers like to call
acknowledgements
it can sometimes be a formulaic
recitation
of names
but because i come out of the
african-american
church tradition
i see it as an opportunity to express
appreciation
for people for their extraordinary
hospitality
first on that list
would be
the students of yale university
because of you
your activism your prophetic voice
your standing
within this community and in the country
i am here to be
with you thank you
i want to express appreciation to
president salovey for extending to me
this wonderful opportunity to be here
uh and express appreciation to his as we
would say my church uh his bride
marta
for not only opening up a pulpit but
also opening up their home as well thank
you
to the dean
members of the faculty certainly the
faculty of yale law school
one of whom i know is present here jay
pottinger
i want to express my appreciation i
certainly want to express my
appreciation to the martin luther king
planning committee i understand
how much work goes into bringing
together a cross-section of the
community
within yale but also beyond
so i want to say
thank you i also want to thank the
university chaplain
reverend coogler and her staff
and i also want to thank
the afro-am house now here's my brothers
and sisters
before i arrived at battelle chapel
that was my senior or rather third year
year law school my first year year law
school this wonderful organization at
yale called the black church at yale
they extended the invitation to me
untried and untested to preach on a
sunday morning
there were maybe 30 or so people there
at the beginning
of that modest sermon
i think there were
one or two at the end
i want to just say thank you to
to the staff and certainly ariza nelson
for her hospitality
please also allow me to extend
appreciation to michael moran who has
been a friend to the naacp
since my freshman year at the end of
aacp i'm a first semester sophomore so i
thank you for your great work and your
great support of the naacp
now uh
my fellow yale
alum and students
there's a large
generally raucous group of people
in this house who represent the nation's
premier advocates for social justice
they would be the members of the naacp
we have in their house the president of
the state conference
president xdale if i could just ask you
to stand
can you put your hands together
members of the state executive committee
could you just please stand
thank you
now they didn't come here alone
there are branch presidents from all
across connecticut
as well as folks representing our youth
in college division of one of whom is
bree
i'm going to ask that our branch
presidents
as well as the rank and file membership
of the naacp whether you're on campus in
connecticut or from any place else in
the country if you could just stand on
your feet here in battelle chapel and
let the people know who you are and who
you represent can you put your hands
together
now before i proceed to my modest
remarks
uh i'd like to share with you
a true story
now this being a pulpit
and not a witness stand it is true
in the sermonic and metaphorical sense
which is to say generally true
my first year at yale law school i had
the opportunity to travel to london
england
to
do a human rights internship
but while i was there i was extended an
opportunity to preach
at one of the great cathedrals of
europe or so i thought
so i found myself on a sunday morning
standing outside of this beautiful
gothic cathedral with spires soaring up
toward the heavens
beautiful stained glass windows
reflecting the multi-hue multi-colored
iridescent beauty of god and standing
outside of this beautiful gothic
cathedral on a sunday morning as a young
naive presumptuous preacher i suppose
presupposed that there were about two
thousand or so people inside waiting to
hear this young naive presumptuous
preacher preach
as i made my way into
the sanctuary
i immediately noticed the obvious
the pastor and exactly two members true
story
one member i'll call miss jones the
other member i'll call miss smith
now as i was preaching i immediately
noticed the obvious
that miss jones immediately fell asleep
true story
but as i was preaching i also noticed
that miss smith
seemed to hang on to every word i had to
say
she nodded her head
she clapped her hands she tapped her
feet she said hallelujah and amen and
all the right liturgical and theological
moments and i thought to myself on this
sunday morning at least i'm reaching one
somebody
so i concluded my modest little homily
made my way out of the pulpit made my
way to the side of the pastor and the
pastor said to me brother brooks i'm
just so sorry
miss jones she falls asleep on everybody
and miss smith she's out of her mind and
did not understand a thing you had to
say
so you can see
why i'm so delighted to be back here at
yale amidst this distinguished
congregation
where there's so many people
who are wide awake and presumably in
your right minds
true story
on this evening
in the still
silence
amidst the powerful reverence
of this magnificently beautiful
sanctuary
many of us recall
the moment
we first heard the
melafluent words
and the melodious voice
of the reverend dr martin luther king jr
on this
evening
the memory of his voice
yet tingles the skin
stirs the soul
quickens the conscience and speaks to
the very depth of who we are as a nation
who we are as a community who we are as
a people amidst this tumultuous time we
find ourselves
in
on this evening
hearing
these words within our hearts
i
have a dream
golden wings to our moral imagination
even at this moment in which the
proposition black lives matter is
questioned
and doubted
even at this moment
on college campuses across the length
and breadth of this republic
the sincerity the democratic intentions
the moral impulse of a generation of
students is being called into question
even at this moment
on this evening
listening to his legacy hearing the
trumpet of history in our hearts
our hearts yet declare that dr king's
voice was and is
peculiarly persuasive
spiritually distinctive
morally unambiguous
if not morally unique
this evening we still wonder we
still as a matter of moral curiosity ask
ourselves what
was it
what
is it about his voice that yet speaks to
us
now in this moment in this place among
this generation of students who are
blessed with a prophetic spirit
his voice
possessed the melodious power
of leontyne price
and paul roberson and yet that voice
transcends song
his voice
lifted up lyrical truths like the
english bard william shakespeare or the
blackboard langston
hughes and yet that voice cannot be
constrained and confined
within
the perimeters of poetry
his voice
yet moves our spirits like the pastoral
symphony and causes our hand our hands
to clap like the negro spirituals
and yet that voice
even this evening amidst this violent
time this tumultuous time this
trepidatious time this anxiety-filled
time this moment in which we question
ourselves as older people and younger
people as a moses generation and a
joshua generation even at this time
in this
moment
we ask ourselves the question
why
does dr king's voice resonate and
reverberate with particularity of
relevance
the conductor arturo tuscanini
said of the african-american soprano
marian anderson her voice was a voice
that comes but once
in human history
and yet
those of you who are scholars of
american rhetoric those of you who are
scholars of american theology those of
you who are scholars of moral philosophy
those of you who are well-read
well-versed
students at yale understand that his
voice may well be
one that comes but once in human history
yet that voice
i want to suggest to you
was a mere echo
of the voice
of god
in human
history
why was his voice so special
why is it on the evening like tonight
we're gathering as a a cross section of
humanity
and all of our foible-filled and flawed
humanity
we come together
diverse in our beauty diverse in the
fragility of our brokenness
we come together to glimpse and glean
his wisdom
why
what was it what is it about the voice
of the reverend
doctor martin
luther
king
jr
i want to suggest to you
particularly those of you
who are students
who feel
a particularly
heavy burden
the timeliness of this moment
the weight of history on your shoulders
with the experience that you have
and with the experience you're yet to
gain
i want to suggest to you
that his voice was special
because
it is
and was
the voice of a prophet
and if you came here this evening
yearning
to hear something
that might encourage your word
encourage your work
give you power
in failing moments
give you strength when you feel weak
and if you're like me
a little older
charged with a different set of
responsibilities
maybe
you want to hear
the secret of his voice
i believe
their instructive words found
in the book of isaiah
and though this is not a sermon
i'd like to
encourage you to hear what another
prophet said that inspired the work of
dr king
in the book of isaiah
in the sixth chapter
we find these words of prophetic power
in the year
that king uzziah died
i saw the lord
sitting upon a throne
high
and lifted up and his train field the
temple above him
stood the seraphim
each had six wings with two he covered
his face and with two he covered his
feet and with two he flew and one called
to another and said
holy
holy
holy ease the lord of hosts
the whole earth is filled
and full of his glory
and the foundations of the threshold
shook at the voice of him who called and
the house was filled with smoke
and i said
woe is me
for i'm lost
i'm a man of unclean lips
and i dwell in the midst of a people
of unclean lips
for mine eyes
have seen the king
the lord of hosts
then flew one of the seraphim to me
having in his hand a burning coal which
he
taken with tongs from the altar and he
touched my mouth and said behold this
has touched
your lips
your guilt
is taken away your sin is forgiven and
i've heard the voice of the lord saying
whom shall i send
and who will go for us
then the lord said
or rather he said
hear am i
send me
here am i
send
me
just for a few moments
as a meditation of encouragement
i want to reflect on three themes
the first of which is
with the vision
comes the voice
with the vision
comes the voice
the second theme i'd like to reflect on
is quite simply flawed
but cold
flawed
but cold
and the third theme i'd like to reflect
on
with you
is there are prophets
among us
there are prophets
among us
my brothers and sisters
in this social justice
struggle
my friends in the naacp
family
and those of you in my yale family
i encourage you to think about
a prophet
by the name
of isaiah
the 8th century prophet
by
virtue of power
and privilege
pedigree
and background
was miracle meritocratically
qualified
to be in the proximity
of power
as a counselor
or an advisor
former dean
anthony cronin
in a book he wrote about the role of
lawyers
spoke about lawyers as statesmen
advisers
counselors to those in power
whereas isaiah a graduate of yale
college he might have gone on to yale
law school
to become a well-connected lawyer
giving advice to the powerful
were you a graduate of yale college he
might have gone on to the school of
management and become a management
consultant and advise those captains of
industry
but the text doesn't tell us that that's
quite what happened
the text tells us that isaiah in the
year king uzziah
caught a vision
and in this vision he saw the lord on
the throne high and lifted up
and the text tells us theological
history tells us
that as a consequence of seeing this
vision
getting beyond
his his his
nearsightedness in his humanity
he cleansed he glimpsed god and as a
consequence he was inaugurated
as a prophet
because he had a vision
he was no ordinary prophet
within the jewish traditions he stands
slightly below moses
his words are lifted up in the morning
service
in the christian tradition he is
his words are quoted over 50 times in
what we call the new testament
he is a prophet of magisterial and
magnificent
power
but the question you have to ask
yourself this evening is what does that
have to do with the relevance and the
urgency of dr king's message on the
campus of yale university amidst the
throes
of what we're grappling with in terms of
diversity
the generational divide
i dare say racial and ethnic distrust
and as
these students
who grew up
in the age of obama
did not arrive on this campus as mere
scholars
they arrived on this campus as citizens
of this republic they arrived on this
campus in the midst of ferguson they
arrived on this campus in the midst of
tamir rice they arrived on this campus
in the midst of freddie gray they
arrived on this campus in the midst of a
social justice revolution and so as a
consequence
you might be asking yourself
what
does isaiah
say about the power
of dr king's voice
dr king
in the i have a dream speech
not the
i have a plan speech
not the i have a strategic plan speech
not the i have a set of objectives and
policy
goals that i'd like to discuss with you
as a nation speech
but the i have a dream speech
translated and transliterated into
ordinary english i have a prophetic
vision speech
and in this speech he invoked the words
of the prophet amos let justice roll
down like waters and righteousness like
a mighty stream
amos
the predecessor and the spiritual
godfather
of isaiah
there's a lesson here
for you young prophets
you have to glimpse
a vision
that's bigger than yourself
even bigger than your generation
now i offer this lesson not because
i'm making any generational assumptions
that i have some wisdom to offer you
but i'm
speaking out of my own brokenness
i'm speaking out of my own vulnerability
i'm speaking out of my experience
as a freshman
ceo after one week of orientation
having staten island and eric garner
happened my second week on the job
then ferguson
then
the charleston nine
students of scripture being assassinated
in my church
and here i am in my first semester of my
sophomore year as president and ceo of
the naacp
i come to you in my brokenness in my
fragility in moral humility saying that
there are times
when i've got to lean
on the wisdom
of the ages
it's hard
to speak with power
it's hard
to speak with courage
it's hard to speak with moral
authenticity
transparency and sincerity
it's hard to confront your enemies to
confront your opponents recognizing that
in them
are weaknesses
foibles
faults
with the old folks called sin
that you may well find in yourself
can i be real with you
after the non-indictment
in ferguson
of the killer of michael
brown
the naacp
announced a march
from
ferguson
to jefferson city missouri from the home
of michael brown to the home of the
governor
a journey of
134 miles
your ceo
not being a particularly gifted student
of geography
didn't realize
that once you leave saint louis it's all
uphill
your president
not being a particularly skilled
climatologist
called for the march
in december
in ice storms
in cold
wondering whether or not i did the right
thing spoke up at the right time
spoke with clarity of vision
wondering whether or not my voice was
sufficiently powerful and authentic
being ambushed by the clan
having the local police declined to
provide protection and the state police
politely ignoring our plea
my voice feeling fragile and shaky and
broken
we arrived in a little town called
rosebud
missouri
where my fellow citizens deciding to
creatively express
their liberties under the first
amendment
decorated the town
with fried chicken boxes
watermelons
and malt liquor bottles
lest we miss the point
they lifted up the n-word with a certain
first amendment vigor
your ceo not being particularly wise
i tell that generation 20 years younger
than me turn those cell phones off we do
not want to agitate these people i need
all these devices shut down don't film
anything don't post anything let us get
in and out of this little town
the sheriff
declines to provide protection
i'm wondering what i'm going to say to
him
until i look over
and see the president
of the missouri state conference of the
naacp
mary ratliff
in her 70s
marching beside her husband
in his 70s but besides 17 year olds and
seven year olds i'm watching them march
in the ice
and in the storm and thinking about her
prophetic spirit thinking about her
understanding of martin luther thing
thinking about her embodiment of king's
ideals when that sheriff
told me
i'm not going to protect you you can't
walk through my town you might as well
get on your bus and drive around
well thinking about that prophetic
vision
these are the words i told him
and not quite as shaky voice
i've been in touch with the attorney
general
and unless you allow me to walk through
your little town
unharmed you explain to him what
happened to my people but you got five
minutes to move and i suggest you move
now
that's not my voice
that's the voice of a prophetic spirit
when you
look at an older generation
a generation less experienced than you
are with respect to social media and
social advocacy
a generation not well versed in the
challenges you're grappling with
but a generation that has survived your
mama's generation your daddy's
generation your grandparents generation
yay even the generation of a few
professors and a few deans
or maybe like me you look at
somebody like mary radliff and think
about dr king and you say to yourself
i'm going to be brave i'm going to be
courageous i'm going to stand up i'm
going to fight i am not going to give up
and never give in because i will stand
on the side of justice no matter what
even if it cost me my life
a prophet
who were he alive today
would be in his eighties
by the name of the reverend dr martin
luther king jr
who said if a man has not found anything
for which he's willing to die
he is not fit to live there is a
generation of older folks who gave their
lives
for what little we have
and i'll just tell you how i think about
them
i ask myself this question
if they did
all that they did
with what little they had why why why
can't i do more with all that i've been
given
it doesn't mean
we don't question our elders it doesn't
mean we engage in some kind of
generation of deference
when you come to the table of truth
your truths have to stand on their own
two feet
you may have tenure
you may have a social security check
but when it comes to the fact
that african-american men are 21 times
more likely to lose their lives at the
hands of the police when it comes to the
fact that they're 2.3 million americans
behind bars 100 million americans with
some form of a criminal record when it
comes to the fact that we have a
generation of young people who have been
criminalized
when you enter that debate
it doesn't matter if you're the
president of the naacp it doesn't matter
if you're a united states senator it
doesn't matter if you're the ceo of a
company what does matter is do you have
prophetic spirit and are you willing to
make a prophetic sacrifice
that's where we are
we have to listen to one another
but it does not mean we have to grant
one another automatic deference
president exhale can tell you
within the naacp we are a profoundly
democratic organization
that means if i say something that
doesn't quite hold true
i got some 15 year olds
and some 75 year olds
who get in my face
and from talking to your president
i gathered
in the conversation that lasted
over an hour
i think maybe you got in his face too
he lived to tell
but the text also tells us
that isaiah
isaiah when he encountered the lord
in this vision
was reminded
of his brokenness
his fragility
his woundedness
isaiah says i'm a man with unclean lips
and i live among a people with unclean
lips
that means we as prophets
are not perfect
we as prophets have to have a certain
moral humility
we as prophets have to come
to an engagement
recognizing
that every claim has to be tested
every moral assertion
has to be tested well i'm not talking
about the first amendment you can go
over to the law school and hear about
that
i'm talking about something more
profound than that
it's called moral discourse
when you sit down with somebody that you
violently
opposed to
who represents everything you stand
against
and you decide to use
one of the most powerful words
in the vocabulary of our republic
love
somebody's saying to me wait wait wait
wait a minute
you were okay until you you got to this
part
no no you you can't you can't be serious
when you have somebody
drive past you
in a pickup truck
with the license plates removed
wearing a ski mask
threatening to shoot you repeatedly
you have to assume
if you're possessed with a prophetic
spirit
that the person
with a gun with an intent to kill with
an intent to harm
is a fellow child of god
i'm not speaking
about a theoretical possibility
i'm speaking about what i've seen
in my freshman year at the naacp
as a black man
i can't drive anywhere with a broken
tail light
a broken signal
a bad paint job
a nice car
a suit
that looks too nice
without having some
police officer pull me over and ask me
99 questions
am i being a citizen not being one
but
when i have my fellow citizens
driving pickup trucks
with the license plates removed
driving past police cars
who are ostensibly there to provide
protection to the naacp
and they threaten to shoot you
repeatedly
you've got to ask yourself am i going to
preach my religion am i going to preach
social justice or am i going to live
social justice
i say to you if we can love people who
threaten to kill us
perhaps we can love one another
when we merely disagree
i can get an amen from the back row i'd
appreciate it
flawed
but cold
flawed lips florida arguments
flawed intentions
flawed behavior
flawed demonstrations
flawed
but cold
can i give you another example
sophomore year
not quite first semester
we look at the state of the voting
rights act
in the wake of shelby versus holder the
supreme court decision which gutted the
coverage formula weakening section five
making pre-clearance difficult making it
difficult for the justice department
to ensure that we have fair voting
we see all across the country a
machiavellian frenzy of voter
disenfranchisement
we're not talking about black and white
disenfranchisement
nostalgic disenfranchisement from 1965
we're talking about multi-colored
disenfranchisement in 2016. here's what
we're seeing
we're talking about african americans
being turned away at the polls because
of
irrational
and uneven
voting
id laws
we're talking about
closing down polling places at the last
minute
we're talking about making it more
difficult to vote not merely for african
americans and hispanics but also people
with disabilities and seniors we're
talking about my mother
who when she was 16 years old and went
to college and stood up for her rights
and participating in civil rights
demonstrations being knocked down by a
fire hose
at 16
50 years later she calls me up and says
son you went to yale law school i live
in georgia they're requiring all of
these ids i can't find my passport i no
longer drive how will i vote
is she being discriminated against based
on her race
on a disability
or her age
and so the naacp faced with this choice
how do we stand up for the right to vote
your flawed formal field ceo
announces a march
from selma alabama to washington dc
again we had real serious geography
problems
the klan in south carolina
being a very indiscreet organization
made clear that they were not going to
have us march through greenville
so though yours truly announced that
we're going to march 867 miles we got it
off we're off by about over
close to 400 miles the journey ended up
being 1002.
we marched from selma alabama to
washington d.c
flawed
but cold we announced the march in the
middle of the summer 104 degree heat 114
degree heat index 85 year old 75 year
old 65 years 17 year olds college
students high school students middle
students flawed but cold
we didn't have all the money we needed
to have we didn't have a great pr firm
we didn't have any posters telling us
that we could get to washington but we
knew we were flawed but called called by
god to stand up for justice to stand up
for righteousness to stand up for the
least disease to stand
flawed but call
this millennial generation
we have august writers
in america's leading newspapers
declaring
that this this generation
is a petulant generation
with a certain kind of finger wagging
arrogance
they say to you
you're upset over little things
trivial matters
hypersensitive as to
all manner of racial and ethnic
and religious and gender slights content
yourselves
to pursue your degrees
leave this activism
alone
they say to you you are not in a
position
to mount a movement
you can tweet
but you can't speak
they say you can post but you can't
protest
i submitted exhibit a
a group of young people in ferguson
who took out their cell phones
filmed
an 18 year old boy lying on the pavement
for four hours by the name of michael
brown they took that image
that selfie
that usee
of injustice
and scented via geostationary satellites
and fiber optic cable and wirelessly all
around the world so much so that they
put the words michael brown on barack
obama's lips in geneva you did zach
you're flawed
but called
you don't have all the answers
and neither do we
we too were flawed
we too are broken
but we need each other
may i humbly remind you
tamir rice was 12.
michael brown was 18. walter scott was
50. eric garner was 50. the victims are
racial profiling a multi-generational
and the opponents of racial profiling
have to be
multi-generational we need everyone in
this fight and unless we stand together
we will fall and fail
together last point
the prophets among us
someone's saying well wait a minute
dr king
that's great for black and white
newsreel of the 1950s and 60s
that's not a youtube moment that's
relevant for me that's not a vine moment
that's relevant for me that's not a
relevant instagram twitter moment for me
okay
let's look at the prophet isaiah
those of you who are biblical scholars
understand
that
isaiah
the book of isaiah was written by a
school of prophets
writing under the name
isaiah
think about it this way
you had younger
more radical
upstart profits
writing under the hashtag
isaiah
that's what happened
check the scholarship
you got the radical upstarts oh y'all
don't believe this
let me let me let me give you an example
turn to this century there was something
called the niagara movement
then an upstart radical
barely well-behaved organization called
the naacp comes along a few years later
then
fast forward
you got
organization led by a young radical
upstart
new to town by the name of the reverend
dr martin luther king who starts his own
organization though he was a member of
the naacp
the southern christian leadership
conference so he leads
the joshua organization relative to the
moses generation fast forward
you got a young
good-looking smooth erudite brother by
the name of julian bond
they created an organization called
snick
because the old guys the old girls
the ulsters the geriatric crowd
in the sclc and the naacp we've been we
got to eclipse you
fast forward
you got a black lives matter movement
young edgy tough
to
experts
in disruptive politics displacing that
geriatric organization
called the naacp
can i tell you the end of the story
50 years from now
25 years from now
your children are going to be saying to
you get the black lives matter movement
out of the way
we need some people in here who are
young
and edgy and radical
who understand technology
that those blm people they got to get
out of the way we got to retire them
here's the here's the truth
we all got to be young
we all got to be radical we all got to
be edgy we've always all got to test
our moral meddle with one another
because be clear
unless we understand that there are
prophets
among us
you're not doing this work because
it's cool you're not doing this work
because it's going to win your inner
friends you're not doing this work
because it's going to help you pass your
exams you're doing this work because
you're caught up with a prophetic spirit
you're doing this work because you
believe in this country you believe in
justice you believe that what you do
matters
when students
when students at yale
who by and large don't have criminal
records
take a stand against the prison
industrial complex you're doing it
because you understand that this era of
mass incarceration has to be brought to
an end
it's the prophetic spirit
the prophets among us
in the residential colleges the prophets
among us
in the library they're prophets among us
walking across campus their prophets
among us back home
with your families among your
grandparents they're prophets among us
they're those of us who are caught up
with the spirit of martin with the
spirit of isaiah with the spirit of amos
we are caught up in a prophetic spirit
and yes
we are in a constructively militant mood
that profits among us
don't let anybody
qualify
what you're doing right now
you're standing in the tradition
of ella baker
you're standing in the tradition of
martin luther king you're standing in
the tradition of julian bond you're
standing in the tradition of w.e.b du
bois you're standing in the blood
sulk sweat stain
sacrifice laden tradition of rosa parks
that's who you are and that's what
you're doing
don't let anyone
engage in moral condescension
and as i take my seat
if you grow discouraged
if you grow weary
i ask that you lift up
these words well known by dr king
and that are kept in the bionicle
rare book library
lift every voice and sing
chill earth and heaven ring
ring with the harmony of liberty
let our rejoicing rise high as the
listening skies let it resound loud as a
rolling sea sing a song full of the
faith that the dog passes taught us sing
a song full of the hope that the present
has brought us facing the rising sun of
our new day begun let us march on let us
march on let us march on let's march on
let us march on till victory is one
good evening everyone i have the lucky
job of following that
wonderful wonderful thank you president
brooks my name is risa nelson i'm the
director of the afro-american cultural
center here at yale i'm also an
assistant dean of yale college and i'm
also the chair of the mlk 2016 planning
committee
iris
thank you
thank you
i received a note just a few hours ago
from miss caroline jackson smith the
third director of the afro-american
cultural center at yale
1981-1989 she shared her journal entry
from mlk day 1986
and her current day reflections which i
thought were just so timely
i recalled martin luther king jr's death
most vividly on january 13 1986 during
the first of many events i helped
planned in honor of the singular moment
in our blood-stained history
it was a huge symphony concert in
woolsey hall the howard university choir
began to sing we shall overcome
their full rich voices filled woolsey
hall like nothing i had ever heard there
fifteen hundred audience members joined
in and their voices rode upward to where
i stood in the balcony
their voices rose a wave of memory and
lost chances and hard-won victories
cresting over me the foam of bitterness
in my mouth my eyes
loss
i remember the very first martin luther
king jr celebration at yale after the
national push
when we fought for and won the holiday
and yale and the center sent a whole bus
to d.c to help lobby for it
it was quite a moment
i can only imagine what a moment that
was especially after last semester
to vision to to witness the triumph of
and the culmination of the tireless work
of students administrators faculty
alumnae alumni and friends in our
community fighting together for what
only made sense the honoring of this
great rights civil rights leader and the
reminder that the work continues
it must i contest in order for humanity
to survive king's dream must be realized
i often reflect a bit more on the days
leading up to mlk day and so i was
reading a bit of where do we go from
here chaos or community in which
reverend dr martin luther king jr states
darkness cannot drive out darkness only
light can do that
hate cannot drive out hate only love can
do that
on saturday i attended a phenomenal film
screening of the price of the ticket
karen thorson's documentary on james
baldwin
and in continued reflection i was
considering baldwin's relationship with
king and other civil rights leaders and
artists of his time and recalled the
quote in the fire next time i imagine
one of the reasons people cling to their
hate so stubbornly is because they sense
once the hate is gone they will be
forced to deal with the pain
in connecting these two quotes i think
how can we get there and together pass
the pain reaching towards love i can't
help but urge myself and others to
consider our pain its sources how we can
find the courage to love through the
pain ourselves especially so that we can
love others
to those who forget king's point of it
is obvious today that america has
defaulted on this promissory note
insofar as her citizens of color are
concerned and often disregarded but
critical point of his i have a dream
speech
the powers that be made a promise to us
all
not just to some
and not just the power the promise of
hope it was a sacred obligation as king
noted
to guarantee the unalienable rights of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
but how can we be happy or even remotely
satisfied as a nation when so many of us
are crippled by racism sexism homophobia
classism dirty water failing schools no
jobs subpar health care institutions
paid to imprison us
and housing we wouldn't even put our
animals in
and so much more
how can we be free how can we live
if even the fullness of our dreams
don't seem to matter how
someone asked at the film screening what
is the price of trust
i was thinking for so many of us it
caused everything
how can we trust each other given our
histories how do we get there i don't
have all of the answers of course but
we have a conversation
we break bread together
we start there start there
who are you this is who i am who are we
in this together
and that takes emotion and truth telling
and honest and transformative listening
and connecting mind and heart and spirit
which is tough for some and especially
in in academia it can be
something that many can't afford
but lest we be silenced and crippled in
complicity we have to be willing to risk
it all and do for love what we thought
we would never do we have to sacrifice
the comfort that we and we know that
it's not going to be easy for any of us
especially if we fear our so-called
transfer of power
the cost of not doing so is far greater
and the implications of which are deadly
it takes learning about our biases and
prejudices about social injustices and
taking part in civic engagement many of
you will be attending the yale civic
leadership initiatives conference on
january 30th i can't wait to hear what
you learn about that and to know what
you'll do with that knowledge
i know that it will lead to a great deal
of work that moves our community
so these are just some ideas starting
ideas for helping our nation make king's
dream truly matter and to be realized
some steps towards the survival of
humanity and transformation of this
world but it takes each one of us as
leaders as president brooks suggested
not always looking outside of ourselves
but seeing and embracing activists in
each of us in each person or at least
copying to the obligation of just one
small action to disrupt distrust fear
pain and injustice and we're all stuck
in this together like it or not
and as lilla watson suggested if you
have come because your liberation is
bound up with mine then let us work
together
this is our obligation to our present
and our future and it is our ticket home
with that
please remember to continue the
reflection the celebration and the work
and know that you are also invited to
join us for the remainder of the mlk
commemorative events tomorrow there's
going to be a public reception for the
artists whose work comprise black pulp
an unprecedented overview of 90 of over
90 years of black image production by
black publishers black artists and by
non-black artists and publishers allied
with foregrounding the black experience
the reception will be held tomorrow at 6
pm at the gallery at 32 edgewood and the
exhibit continues through march 11th
also tomorrow the fm house and the
silica center will be holding a memorial
service honoring james
earl cheney andrew goodman and michael
schwerner young very young freedom
fighters who were abducted and killed by
the klan during 1964's freedom summer
murders the event will take place
tomorrow again at 6 30 at the silica
center 80 wall street
the house will be holding a poetry in
the house i mean afro-american cultural
center the house
we'll be holding a poetry slam in an
open mic on friday at 8 at 211 park
street if you don't know you should
performers will have the opportunity to
share their poems and work that relate
to civil rights movements and social
justice's social justice issues here and
around the world
king said life's most persistent and
urgent question is what are you doing
for others so we hope that you will
respond to that question by
participating in dwight hall's annual
mlk day of service this saturday 9 a.m
to 1 p.m to register you can visit
dwighthall.org the house will also be
hosting celebration of community and
spirit that connects us all at the mlk
soiree this saturday starting at 9 00 pm
again at 2 11 park
and lastly the black church at yale and
the university church incredi in yale
the university church edl will hold a
joint worship service on sunday january
31st at 10 am this will also be held at
211 park
please keep in mind that the house its
resident groups and many campus and
community partners are going to be
kicking off black history month soon the
theme is on routes rebirth and
renaissance and we have a lot of great
events
that are open to the community free we
want everybody to come out we'll be
celebrating black traditions cultures
contributions to our world going back to
the cradle of humanity
to today and some of the events include
the digital diaspora family reunion with
filmmaker thomas allen harris the annual
black solidarity conference the black
panthers film screening and talk back
with director stanley nelson again the
black pulp art exhibit the black women's
retreat rodney king performed by roger
genvir smith
all black everything a first annual
festival celebrating black life
so please do check for the schedule it's
going to be on our website it'll be
posted in the inner city news so check
it out and finally thank you again to
president brooks thank you to the mlk
planning committee for helping bring
this moment together abigail troy amber
drungle brianna burroughs diane young
turner gabby cujo wilkes ian oliver
karen king
michael morand and cassie
oates
nicole tinton orlando yarborough paige
tucker peter crumlish
and yours truly
and many thanks again to the yale dean's
office the office of the secretary and
vice president for student life
the naacp and miss bria baker
and many other supporters of tonight's
event and those throughout our
celebration so that is all for now go in
peace and do good work thank you
everybody
thank you dean nelson we had a quick
conference on the sidebar i want to
bring our guest speaker back to the
podium for 30 seconds
i just want to leave you with these
words thank you so much for your
hospitality and your love
and i want to encourage anyone here who
may not be a member
of the naacp
please join the naacp
thank you
and there's a
there's a table in the back where you
can sign up and
uh for those of you don't do so tonight
you can also join online join the naacp
thank you fellow prophets
you